[Applaudissements]
quand je faisais du vélo c'est mon frère
qui m'entrainait et en fait on délirait
force parti d'un délire où on disait ben
toi donc lui tu pilotera et puis moi je
pousserai et est en fait voilà j'ai
voulu vraiment tester ce que ça faisait
une descente de bob donc
voilà j'ai contacté la pilote margot boc
et puis donc ça c'était pendant le
confinement donc au printemps en 2020
moi c'était vraiment d'avoir dans un but
c'était plaisir quoi vraiment découverte
et au final j'ai accroché tout de suite
[Musique]
qualités physiques c'est les mêmes parce
qu'il faut être à la fois fort rapide et
donc puissant mais par contre je passe
d'un vélo donc un sport portée
ben c'est de la course à pied en fait
pour s'entraîner on fait de la
musculation et de l'athlétisme du sprint
et là par contre c'est enfin moi j'ai
jamais couru de ma vie il a fallu que
j'apprenne à courir
enfin savoir voilà bien pousser bien
monter le genou la poste du pied au sol
c'est plein de petits détails mais c'est
hyper technique la course c'est très
très technique donc c'était vraiment un
j'allais dire un pari un défi énorme
quoi
je suis sélectionné en tant que
remplaçante donc c'est vrai que de ce
côté là je suis un petit peu déçu parce
que je voulais titulaire mais c'est
comme ça c'est le sport on a fait des
tests de sélection et ça c'est pas
passer pour un petit peu plus de 2
centièmes donc donc c'est un peu rageant
mais bon c'est comme ça et moi mon
objectif dans la sava etre de soutenir
l'équipe et puis d'être d'être présente
si des fois ça se passe mal
malheureusement pour la titulaire en
fait il faut absolument que je reste en
forme et que je reste comment dire
performante
[Applaudissements]